[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN GRAHAM:
I'm Adrian Graham.
I'm a cloud solutions architect
for media and entertainment
at Google based in Los Angeles.
I spent about 20 years in visual
effects at different VFX houses
around the world,
working on pipelines.
Basically writing the
glue that ties together
proprietary and
custom applications.
So today, sharing the
stage with Yannick.
I'll let Yannick
introduce himself.
YANNICK GUILLERM: Morning.
My name is Yannick.
I work for Elastifile,
where I get
to play with a lot of cool
toys in the media rendering
and stuff.
So yeah, working with
the partners, and Google
is a major one for us.
I'm French, so I won't be
able to hide the accent.
I've been in the media industry
through several companies
with storage and backup and
archive software, so pretty
cool space.
And super happy to be here.
We've been working in the past
few months with building a demo
and building some cool stuff
that we'll see at the end.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Yeah, what
you're going to see today is--
so because I come from VFX
and animation background,
we're going to--
it's a very interesting
workload as a way
to pressure test and
really push the boundaries
and push the envelope of
the Elastifile file system,
storage file system,
because we're
going to be hitting it
from multiple angles
with a lot of reads and a lot
of writes and a lot of data
and a lot of activity.
And you'll see that
throughout the demo
and throughout some of
the presentation here.
But what we're going
to talk about today,
we're going to give you first
an overview of the Elastifile.
But first let's pose the
question and look at--
there we are-- and look
at what the problems are
that we're dealing with today.
And there's a few
slides here that
indicate the growth and
explosion of content out there.
And when we talk about
content in this case,
we're talking about
visual effects film,
but any type of content creation
like commercials, VR generation
and delivery, as well as
streaming and transcoding,
there's a lot of
workloads around that.
And one example here is just
looking at the number of shots
compared to about 20 years
ago in "Titanic," compared
to a new film like "Avengers,"
10x the amount of shots.
But if you think about
the content of the shots,
it's not just a ship
jumping out of the water
and breaking in half and
with a few fluid simulations.
If anybody's seen "Avengers,"
it is just-- every single shot
is just full of hundreds of
thousands of individual assets,
possibly tens of millions or
billions of points in terms
of fluid dynamics simulations
or dust or explosions or debris
simulations.
And all that needs
to be stored and all
that needs to be computed.
But if we focus in
on one aspect of what
we're going to talk about
today, which is rendering.
Rendering is, for those of you
who are not familiar with it,
it's the process of taking--
how do you define
rendering in one sentence?
The process of taking a 3D set,
an environment and characters
and assets and
textures and generating
an image, a still, 2D, two
dimensional image out of it.
And remember that films are
made up of a bunch of frames
and they play back at
24 frames per second.
And each frame might take
minutes or hours or even
days to render.
There's one example, some
frames from Pixar's "Inside Out"
took up to 33 hours to render.
A single frame.
YANNICK GUILLERM: That's insane.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: And that's
just one iteration.
Artists tend to
iterate over and over.
So they have all
these strategies
for sort of faking it and
making it seem like a lot--
like they'll do low res or
they'll do low quality and then
they'll just only crank
up the quality of the end,
but that's a 33-hour render.
But then when you think
about the total number
of compute hours required
to generate everything
in a whole film, you know,
172,000 frames is many,
many core hours.
Over 5 million core hours.
And again, that's only
if you render it once.
Typically artists will
iterate over and over
until they get something that--
YANNICK GUILLERM:
Until they like it.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Right, yeah.
I mean, Pixar is pretty
crazy because they
render everything in frame.
That means that every shot is--
there's a smaller amount
of things being done,
but other film like
"Avengers," they'll
render individual elements.
Like the character will
be rendered separately
from the background.
So those are separate renders
and separate processes.
So how do you
handle all that data
and how do you farm it
out to your render farm?
We partnered with Sony
Picture Image Works
to open source their
cue management system.
Cue management
system is essentially
a job manager and a scheduler
that can push out data and keep
track of resources and feed
jobs to individual resources
on a very strict
dependency type scale
so that you've got jobs that
are dependent on other jobs that
need to finish before this job
starts, et cetera, et cetera.
That's what a cue
manager's really good at.
So Sony Image Works developed
this over the last 15 years,
and they partnered with
us to open source it.
So we've stripped
out all of their--
worked with them to strip
out their proprietary
or other external dependencies
and it's available for free
on GitHub.
And there's
documentation online.
Now the reason I'm
mentioning this is
because the presentation
after this-- not here--
we'll talk about it.
I'll show you where
to go afterwards--
is a deeper dive into
OpenCue if you're interested.
So just stay tuned.
All right.
So I'm going to--
oh, we're going to talk about--
YANNICK GUILLERM: Yeah, you
do the first few ones and I--
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Yeah, sorry.
We're doing this very casually.
By the way, Yannick and I just
spent four days in Las Vegas
at NAB, National
Association of Broadcasters,
so we have the Vegas voice.
And we're all cool
and worked up.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
When we talk about legacy
storage architecture,
I want to look at what's
hitting the shared file
server, what you
see in the middle,
in this type of workload.
And so there's
artist workstations--
and we're not talking
about anything on the cloud
right now.
We're just talking
about everybody
with a really expensive
workstation under their desk.
And they're loading files and
they're reading and writing
assets and they're talking
to their asset management
database, and they're
deploying jobs
to things like the
render workers.
And render farms can
typically, depending
on the size of the company--
I think WETA, which is
in New Zealand, which
does the Hobbit films and all
the Lord of the Rings films--
they have one of the largest
render farms in the world.
I think it's something in
the order of 120,000 cores.
So obviously each
machine, each blade
is made up of a
few of those cores.
There might be eight
cores or 16 cores,
but you've got thousands
of render workers
all hitting storage
at the same time.
And in render
workloads, typically,
at the start of
the process they'll
read a whole bunch
of data into memory
and then they'll sit there
and compute in memory.
And then when
they're finished they
write a finished
rendered frame which
gets written back to the disk.
Now that's just for rendered.
If you think about things
like liquid simulations
or fluid dynamic
simulations, those
are generating cache data.
And that's every frame,
they're generating
possibly gigabytes
or even terabytes
of data, which is not unique
across different workloads
because if you think about
scientific visualization
and oil and gas
exploration, they also
generate massive amounts
of simulation cache data
that could in turn be read by
the people on the workstations
or by the render farm.
There's a lot of transfer
going back and forth.
In the olden days,
back when I had hair,
we had multiple
facilities that needed
to synchronize between
on prem locations,
possibly around the US or
possibly even across to the UK
or to Asia.
So there's a lot of
transfer and sync
data coming in and out there.
And finally, if you've got
lots of assets and lots
of production data
to manage, you're
going to need some sort
of management database.
And that may not be reading
and writing massive amounts,
but it's many hundreds
or thousands of QPS,
queries per second, that
is hitting the storage
to do things like file
comparisons and asking
has this file changed since
the last time it was read,
and maybe there needs to be some
sort of front-end cache there.
So to summarize, you need
scalability and durability.
Also, don't forget you
need to provide things
like snapshots so that--
and I've done this before.
I accidentally deleted a
file on a Linux system.
There's no trash folder
on a Linux workstation.
So how do you get
that file back?
You can go into the snapshot
folder and pull it back.
I've done that countless times.
But then you also need
to think about archive.
What's happening at
the end of a film
is they'll sort of
clean all of the assets
up and make sure to get rid of
any data that they don't need,
and then they'll archive it.
And they might need to
restore it at some point
if they've got a
sequel of a film,
that they'll need to pull
an existing asset down.
So that needs to be highly
available and easy to find
and searchable.
Disaster recovery, as well.
And a lot of customers are
concerned about regionalization
of disaster recovery.
They want it somewhere
completely outside
of the existing region.
We'll talk about that in a bit.
And snapshotting, we
talked about earlier.
But there's also sync
mechanisms as well.
And this just sort of
gets a little deeper
into the notion of
multiple facilities
that need access to
the same data that
aren't too far apart for both
sides to read the same storage.
So you can have multiple
storage appliances
all synchronizing together.
That's an important
feature as well.
Migrating data from on prem
supports more hybrid workflows.
So if you've got on
prem infrastructure
and you're still using it, and
you want to burst to the cloud,
for example, you need
a way to get the data
from on prem to the cloud
efficiently and selectively
so that you could then
render frames, for example,
on the cloud.
And then, of course, cost.
How much do you want to
spend and how performant
do you need it to be and
what kind of data egress
are you looking at?
Egress, of course, the data you
need to take out of the cloud.
In this case, we're not going to
take any data out of the cloud,
but if you need to take
the rendered frames
and write them back
to your on prem,
you need to consider what
mechanism is doing that.
So enter Elastifile.
YANNICK GUILLERM: Awesome.
Thank you.
Thanks, Adrian.
So good transition.
We're going to focus a little
bit more onto the storage.
The storage in Google is going
to be the back end to all
those operations.
Doing the rendering, doing
the fluid simulation.
So you will need a storage
that can scale, that's fast,
that's secure, and
all the good stuff.
So we're going to go into
a little bit of details--
not too crazy
details, because we
could spend hours going into
size of blocks and things
like that.
But really a high
level of what it is.
And at the end you'll see
I'll have a bunch of links
so that you can launch a
quick lab or go to marketplace
and be launching it
yourself and test it.
So who's Elastifile, first?
So we're a software company
that was founded in 2013.
We have offices here in
the US in the Bay Area,
in Santa Clara.
The HQ headquarter
is in Tel Aviv.
So that's where
all the R and D is,
and we have a presence
in Europe as well,
in London and Amsterdam.
We're really a team
of storage experts.
We have deep expertise into
distributed system, optimizing
applications, and
IOPS and throughput
and all the good thing.
And we've been at Google, a
partner for quite a bit now,
and it's been a blast.
It's really been
very good for us.
Elastifile in one sentence.
It's pretty easy at the end.
Elastifile is a scale-out
NAS for the cloud.
So it's a scale-out
NAS for Google.
Not all of you but
some of you, I guess,
use [INAUDIBLE] or NetApp
or [INAUDIBLE] on prem.
So it's what that
is, but in Google.
So it's going to
give you file access,
NFS file access for
your application
to run in the cloud.
So the cool thing with that is
that you can migrate and move
your traditional legacy
applications to the cloud
today, and when you do
rendering, when you do flight
simulation, when you do even--
we did some tests
with Adobe Premiere,
all those applications talk
in a NFS [INAUDIBLE] system.
None of them talk S3 or
the other object protocols.
So you don't have to
refactor your application
to bring them to the cloud.
It's there, it
scales, and you'll
see that it's supported in
pretty much every region where
GCP is.
So it's a software only.
So the cool thing
with that is that you
can install it in all the
regions where GCP is available.
And we take advantage
of all the new features
that those guys are
going to come up with.
New disks, new versions
of the instances
with better CPU and all that.
We don't depend on
machines that you have
to install in data centers.
It's all using GCP resources.
So right out the door,
all the instances
that those guys are
going to come up with
are going to be
usable on our site.
It's Posix NFS so Google,
NFS protocol that you know.
No app factoring.
So you bring your app into GCP,
you launch an instance, a Linux
machine, and you install
a blender, a rendering
application.
You mount the Elastifile via
NFS and you're good to go.
You put your data in and
you can start rendering.
It gives you a global namespace.
You'll see at the end we're
going to launch around
3,000 nodes on the
cluster, so it's
going to shake it a little bit.
And all those
applications are going
to use the same namespace.
So you won't have
having any limitations
into creating multiple
smaller volumes
and having to manage all that,
that crazy number of volumes.
It scales.
So today if you
go on Marketplace,
and you'll see that we have
a managed service as well.
You can start in just
a couple of terabytes
and scale it crazy.
You can go multiple petabytes
and as big as you want,
and shrink it back whenever
you don't need it anymore.
And it has a whole bunch
of enterprise features
that are pretty cool.
Snapshots, we
dedupe, compression,
we'll go into details
that a bit about tiering
to cloud storage so you don't
want to leave your data out
to the [INAUDIBLE] NFS
tier once you don't use it.
So we have a tiering
mechanism where
you're going to be able to
create policies to move them
onto cloud storage.
In a nutshell, really, a high
level of the architecture.
So the Elastifile
cloud file system
is going to be really the
cloud file system into GCP.
It comes with some
of the modules,
as well, to be able
to move content
between your on prem
or other clouds to GCP
and do the tiering.
So Cloud Connect is going to
be the module that you can use.
It's a data mover, so it can
read pretty much anything
through NFS and move it to
cloud storage in Google.
And then once you're ready to
work with your applications
in the cloud, you're going
to be able to move that,
to like hydrate the NFS
layer for your applications
to use the content on NFS.
So Elastifile is going to
be installed on the Google
instances, and it's
going to take advantage
of the different types
of disks that you
have in instances, local SSDs,
PD-SSD, and standard PDs,
depending on what
kind of configuration
you want, what
kind of performance
you want out of this
storage as well.
You can access it
through RESTful APIs
as well to say, hey, I
want to create a volume.
I want to be able to do a
sync between two clusters.
There's a very rich
API underneath that
allows you to script
it and write some code
around the applications.
So we'll go a little
bit into more details
about different modules
and I'll give you
some examples of
the architectures
that we support with those
types of modules [INAUDIBLE]..
So really, when we
started to work with that
and defined what we were
going to do during the demo,
there's really two
types of architecture
when it comes to bursts and
moves the main media content
to the cloud and compute.
You have a hybrid architecture.
So some of your content
is-- well, it's on prem.
You have your NAS or you have
whatever [INAUDIBLE] on prem,
and you want to be able
to move it to the cloud,
launch a cluster, and be able
to compute and get it back.
So this is like a
typical architecture
you would see with
the Elastifile cloud
connect between your local NAS
and cloud storage in Google
so you can transfer data.
In the meantime, after,
before, it doesn't matter,
you can quickly launch
an Elastifile cluster.
And you'll see later
on that you can do it
from Marketplace as a
managed service in something
like Terraform.
We fully support
Terraform as well.
Whenever you're ready, you
hydrate on the NFS side,
you compute, and then you can
bring it back on prem whenever
you're finished with it.
So it's really a burst of
your computer to cloud.
You push it to the
cloud, you compute,
and you bring it back on prem.
Another pretty cool
architecture as well--
and this is really
what we're going
to demo at the end of the
session, is a virtual studio.
So you're building a full
production environment
in the cloud.
And what you have, really, on
your laptop and on your machine
is just a super light
client like Teradici client,
for example, that
is super optimized
for graphical workflows,
and your Adobe stations,
your rendering stations, and
all of the compute for the media
is going to be
installed in the cloud
and taking advantage of that,
of Elastifile and the back end
underneath to be able to
compute all that stuff.
So really the main difference
is that in that situation,
you don't really transfer
much stuff into the cloud.
It's already there, or it's
been transferred before,
and you're going to be able to
work pretty much from anywhere
on your content in the cloud.
All right, so again,
without going too crazy
into the details,
Elastifile is going
to be able to support multi-zone
and multi-region right away.
So again, everywhere GCP is
available, we're available.
Multi-zone means
that at the top,
you have your applications,
all the different [INAUDIBLE]
nodes, they go through
a load balancer
to write all the different
contents on to the storage
nodes at the bottom.
And those can be installed
in different regions.
So we do multiple copies of
the data into, in that example,
in West 1 with A, B, and C
so that if one of the regions
becomes available, your
application will still
be able to access the data
through the load balancer
onto another region.
And it's going to be
transparent for the application.
Similar to that is
the multi-regions.
So what I forgot to mention
is that in the multi-zone
you do a sync copy of the data.
So when one of the
render node writes data,
it's going to be
acknowledged when
all the copies are
going to be written
into the different zones.
With multi-region this is going
to be an async replication
into a different
zone for a DR mirror.
You have the production, you
have a mirror somewhere just
in case, that example,
West 1 because unavailable,
you can quickly
switch to Central 1
and continue to compute in your
work onto a different region.
And that's done in Elastifile
through the management console.
ClearTier is really
that module that
allows you to do tiering
between your Elastifile
[INAUDIBLE] NFS layer and
cloud storage in Google.
And it can be manual or it
can be done through policies
that you define.
Typically, all the files
then on the NFS layer that
haven't been touched in the
last three hours, for example,
move it to cloud storage.
And a very cool
thing is that it's
going to be transparent
to the application.
It's going to be present
in the namespace.
If the files is on the NFS
player or the object layer,
same thing for the application.
Whenever it reads it, it's going
to read it from either cloud
storage or NFS,
depending on where
the file has been positioned.
So it's pretty cool
to kind of reduce
the cost of the
infrastructure and be
able to move some of that
content to cloud storage
and even for use cases such as,
I don't know, OTT, streaming
content distribution,
using applications,
then I'm going to use
object storage, for example,
and object protocols.
CloudConnect, again, I've
talked about it already.
It's really a data
mover that allows
you to move content
in GCP from your
on prem or from another cloud.
And it's going to
do a diff sync.
So you can do the first
sync of your files.
It's going to move
everything in cloud storage,
and when you have files changing
on prem and you do a new sync,
it's going to move
only the files that
have been changed or added or
modified, things like that.
And it's going to do
compression and dedupe
as well whenever transferring
the files to cloud storage.
I think the last one
on the features is--
we talked about-- you
mentioned that, the snapshot is
really important whenever you
want to protect your data.
So we do support snapshots.
We have our snapshot
mechanism to disk and to GCS.
And what's pretty cool is that
in many enterprise storage
that you would see, not going to
name any one, but usually what
they do is that they reserve a
space on your tier one storage
to put the snapshots,
and that's what it is.
Like 10%, 30% of the
storage, the tier one storage
is going to be reserved
for the snapshot.
With Elastifile, it's going
to be a little bit different.
You can take a snapshot, leave
it to disk for, I don't know,
a period of time
that you define,
and then it moves to GCS so that
you don't consume your tier one
storage with the snapshots.
Just taking a look
at the time here.
We just announced last
week a managed service
in Google, which
is a service that
have been in beta since
the end of last year.
Managed service
means that it's going
to be fully embedded in Google,
in the UI, in the billing.
And you're going
to launch it as you
would launch a Cloud SQL or a
BigQuery or things like that.
So in a matter of just a
few steps and a few clicks
you launch an Elastifile cluster
and you get an NFS [INAUDIBLE]
at the end, an IP,
and a shared volume,
a volume that you can mount
and use on your application.
And that's pretty cool,
because underneath it's
all going to be managed
by Google and Elastifile,
so you don't even see the
instances in the console,
in the Google console.
Just to give you an idea
of the pricing of that,
it will go from $0.10 a gig
per month up to $0.30 a gig per
month.
So we have three
different models.
Really the difference
between the three models
are the performance that you
require for your applications.
And it comes with different
types of clusters.
So the minimum size of the
cluster that you can launch
is going to be a
little bit different.
So if you need super
high-speed performance,
you would go to the
performance optimized.
And if you need a
little bit less,
you would have a tendency to
go to the capacity optimized
for your apps.
Three ways to deploy
Elastifile today, really.
From the marketplace.
So you go there and you
do a search on Elastifile,
and then you launch it
as an unmanaged service,
meaning you're going
to see the instances.
It's up to you to add
instances, add capacity.
You can do it through
a managed service
that we just launched
GA this week,
but it's beta for
quite a while, where
it's going to be super, super
easy for you in a few clicks
to launch it.
And we've been doing some
work with Terraform as well.
I think there's going to be
a link at the end on that
as well, like a QR code.
We did a tutorial to
launching a cluster,
adding capacity, shrinking
the cluster, and delete
the cluster, simply
with a Terraform script.
So we're going to take a
look at a little bit of that
in the demo as well, but we
have many different ways--
well, many [INAUDIBLE].
We have a native GUI
in Elastifile for you
to take a look at CPU
utilization, throughput, IOPS,
et cetera, et cetera,
because you want to track
what's going on in the cluster.
If you have a--
I don't know, a client that
is using all the bandwidth
or if you have a
node that went down.
So all that stuff is going to
be monitored into Elastifile
for logging, for
updates, for being
able to monitor the resources,
reporting any specific issue
onto an agent, detect
anomalies, like a disk went down
it's going to give you
alerts and all the good stuff
that you would see
in a UI, all that
is going to be in Elastifile.
But then on top of that--
and we'll take a look at that in
the demo a little bit as well--
we have Grafana templates and
we set up Stackdriver as well so
that you can have a little bit
of a different and deeper view
of the stats, like how
many clients what's
the client that is using
the most bandwidth how
many connections you have at
the same time in a cluster.
So it's enriching the
native Elastifile GUI
with more monitoring
elements into GCP.
Last but not least,
before we go to the demo,
just to give you an idea of the
performance of such a cluster,
because we talk about rendering
and editing and all that.
So to be able to
do that, you need
to be able to deliver throughput
and IOPS onto the storage.
So we worked a lot with
Google on doing some test
on different clusters here.
So one is based on
PD-SSD, another one
is based on local
SSD and standard PD.
You will see that
the second one has
got a dual application, yes,
because it's using local SSD.
And the local SSD, whenever
you lose the instance
you lose the data.
So we do multiple copies
on different instances
so that if it happens
you don't lose the data.
So we're not going to go too
crazy into the details of which
one is the best and
things like that,
but really to give
you a high level
view of what it can deliver,
take a look, for example,
at the throughput with a read
on the four node configuration.
You will get around
three gigabytes
per second of throughput.
And if you move
that to 32 nodes,
it's going to reach nearly
17 gigabytes per second.
Meaning what?
Meaning that the
system is really
going to scale in
capacity when you add
nodes, but it's going to
scanning performance as well.
And in a near linear fashion.
Same for the IOPS.
You can see the four nodes
is going to deliver 96k IOPS
and up to 760k IOPS onto a 32
node configuration with PD-SSD.
Now if you move to local,
this is going to be faster.
The local SSDs are going to be
much faster than the PD-SSDs,
but again, it comes
with having to do
multiple copies
on different nodes
to be able to sustain losing
an instance, for example.
But look at the throughput here
onto a 32 node for the read
and write.
The read, typically, you're
reaching nearly 29 gigabytes
per second on the cluster.
So you can do a lot
of stuff with that,
rendering and editing
and all the good stuff.
All right.
Show, don't tell.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: All right.
YANNICK GUILLERM:
Let's take a look at--
ADRIAN GRAHAM: After all
that telling, let's--
YANNICK GUILLERM: Yeah, exactly.
ADRIAN GRAHAM:
--do some showing.
YANNICK GUILLERM: Let's take
a look at the real stuff.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: All
right, so first I'm
going to show you a
short video that we did.
Last Next, if
anybody was here, you
might remember what we
call the robot dance party.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is a
one-minute animation
that we did as part of
what's called the Virtual
Studio or the cloud studio.
And we did this at Next.
Over the three days of
the show we actually
had artists working on
virtual workstations
at the show in the
booth doing things
like animating these robots
and lighting them and texturing
them and rendering them,
all totally on the cloud.
Everybody had what's called
a zero client on their desk
and a couple monitors,
keyboard, mouse, tablet,
and they were all working out
of the different remote data
center, some in
LA, some in Oregon,
and there was even
one artist working out
of LA who was doing
like a video chat.
You could-- there was
a blog post about this.
It was a lot of fun.
So we're going to use
these assets to just show
some of the capabilities
of Elastifile.
and I'm going to connect
to a virtual workstation.
Just on my laptop here,
I've got a PC-over-IP client
that I'm going to--
a software client
that I'm going to log into
my virtual workstation here.
And this is located in our
LA data center, which is--
I didn't test the ping.
I think it's probably--
from the convention
center, from here
it's probably like 25
milliseconds or something.
But I'm running a standard
Linux workstation that's
running [INAUDIBLE] 7, and I've
got these scene files here.
And I'm running an
application called Maya,
if anybody is
familiar with that.
It's one of the main 3D
application packages out there.
It's very heavily used
in VFX and animation.
And here we've got all the
animation that's already
been baked and everything.
There's tons of
assets in this scene.
Like I was mentioning
earlier, each of these robots
is a separate asset that has
separate animation as an asset,
and then all the
pieces of the set
and the environment
and the lighting
and all the texturing
and everything.
It's all separate, but it's
all combined into one scene
and rendered through
in a single frame.
So let's look through
the main render camera,
and we'll choose a.
Frame I think this guy's name
is-- these two robots that
are named Fred and Ginger.
I think this is Fred.
And so we're going to
click the Render button,
and I'll show you how elaborate
and complicated the process is.
So this is going to
render a single frame.
And you'll see that it
blipped a little bit.
That's because it's
calculating motion blur.
It's calculating where
the shutter opens
and where the shutter
closes, to use
sort of a metaphor of
an actual film camera.
So it's doing a whole lot
of computing of the scene
right now, and it's
going to build--
we're rendering
in an application,
a renderer called V-Ray.
V-Ray is by a company
called Chaos Group,
and we're pretty closely
partnered with them.
Actually, they have something
called Chaos Cloud, the V-Ray
Cloud, which runs on GCP.
It's a render farm as a service.
There's a lot of
this-- by the way,
you can see there's a demo
pod at the show, in, I think--
there's like a
small media section.
I actually haven't been there
because I got in last night.
YANNICK GUILLERM: They
have the same setup.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: They
have the same setup,
so if you want to dive
deeper into this you can.
I want to see where
this render's at.
So I'm going to go and open my--
so it's actually rendering--
oh, I've got the window behind.
There we are.
So anyways, it's performing
a render right now,
and you can see it's
working in the background.
I actually didn't pop
open the render viewer,
but there we are.
So it's running this render.
And it's prepared all that data.
But it's only rendering
it inside this one square.
So just give you an idea
of how complicated and
compute-intensive rendering
a single frame is,
it's still not finished.
And you can see it sort of
iterating over and over.
It's called a
progressive renderer.
So these frames, by
the way, they take--
I think the final
frames, some of them
took from between
20 and 60 minutes
to render, depending
on what the content is.
Some frames are faster because
you have less in the frame.
Some take longer because maybe
there's more motion blur.
Motion blur typically
requires more compute power
because it's got to
interpolate between all
the motion of the animation.
Anyway, so that's one frame,
and not even a whole frame,
and that's how long it took.
And it was actually
pretty low resolution.
So when it comes time to
render the whole sequence--
remember this is a
sequence of frames.
I can grab the time slider
and slide through the duration
of the shot--
if I want to send
that to a render farm,
we're going to use
something called OpenCue,
like I was mentioning earlier.
So I'm just going to just
quickly set a couple of names
here, but I'm going to
define a few variables here.
I'm going to render
the default layer,
choose a camera to render.
Usually you have
these pre-populated,
but of course I don't.
And I'm going to select
my start and end frames.
We'll do like frames
520 to 740, for example,
and I can leave pretty
much everything else there.
One important thing is what's
called this chunk size.
That's how many frames to render
per job that gets deployed.
So when I'm done,
I'm just going to--
my screen resolution has changed
since the last time I ran this.
I'm going to click Submit and
it's saying Job Submitted.
So now I can go to what's
called a cue commander
and look at all the jobs under
the cue commander, and open--
sorry, now I just quit.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'll just relaunch it.
Cue commander, I'll
launch the cue GUI.
And this is where I could
start to see all of my-- here,
there's the job that
I just submitted.
If I double click that,
these are all my frames
that have been cued up.
All right, so pretty simply, we
just cued up hundreds of frames
and they're all
organized and managed
and they're all reading
off the Elastifile.
So all that data-- by the
way, this virtual workstation
has Elastifile mounted under
the slash projects namespace.
So everything is hitting
that slash projects mount
point, that volume,
including all the render
workers and everything else.
So this is one job.
And that's great, but
I'm just one person.
What if I was a whole studio?
What if I was a whole--
hundreds of artists
working in a studio?
Well, I can deploy
many thousands of jobs
to sort of artificially fake the
workload of a studio out there.
And you can see, I've got
three managed instance groups,
each with 1,000 render
workers in them.
And I'm going to deploy--
I've got a script
that will deploy
hundreds and hundreds
of jobs and just fill up
the farm instantly.
So it's-- I actually
forget, it's cue renders--
no, I'm forgetting the code.
Dash project all--
no, it's dash--
dash project, sorry, equals all.
So watch this.
You're going to see a whole
bunch of jobs getting launched.
You might see a couple
alembic errors or something
because it's just
substituting-- there he goes.
You could ignore those.
But this is all just command
line submitting these jobs.
And while these are being
submitted, now we can watch--
look at this.
We've got all these
jobs just being cued up
and the farm is being stuffed
full of all these tasks.
So each job, you could see,
consists of hundreds of frames.
For example, you can
just reload and you
can see there's all
these different jobs.
And this is a wide
variety of jobs.
So right now is
actually probably
a good time to go and look at--
YANNICK GUILLERM: Take a
look at the cluster itself.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Look
at the cluster itself.
So I'll let you take over and go
through some of the monitoring
tools.
YANNICK GUILLERM: So--
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Just
click in the middle.
I'm sorry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YANNICK GUILLERM: All right.
No, no.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Just
click there and click
in the middle of the window.
Great.
Right there, just right there.
OK, there you go.
YANNICK GUILLERM: OK.
So we're going to
be connect-- we're
connected to the clusters,
to the Elastifile cluster
right now.
So that's what the
GUI looks like.
There's going to be lots of
different things in there
and we're not going to go
into details of all of those.
But we have a bunch
of data containers
that have been created.
This is for some of
the tools that we
use for those render nodes.
This is the main
one, the ECFS render.
So there's not crazy amount
of data on the volume right
outlet.
For each of those
containers you can
set soft quotas and hard
quotas as well for NFS quotas.
On those shares,
you're also going
to be able to define if
you want to do snapshots,
if you want to be able
to do tiering to objects.
We haven't set it up here to be
able to move data to the cloud
storage, but this is something
that you would do in here.
You want to do dedupe,
compressions, you know,
things like that.
On the main window here, we
will probably [INAUDIBLE] you
will see a peak of
content coming in.
So it means that
we're seeing now
all the jobs that have been
launched at the same time.
I don't know how many
jobs you launched.
It's a total off--
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Well, there's
like 120-something jobs,
but each job has
hundreds of frames.
Sub jobs.
YANNICK GUILLERM: See
this, for example?
This is going to track
the number of connections
that you have on the
cluster at the same time.
So we have a lot
of clients, each
of them mounting the Elastifile
NFS volume at the same time,
so they're all
reading and writing
that content on the
cluster at the same time.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: See,
it's climbing as we're--
YANNICK GUILLERM: Yeah, it's
climbing because the processes
are running and getting kicked.
So you can see here
that the cluster
is getting hammered a little
bit with throughput and IOPS.
We're around 1.2 gigabytes
per second during the work
that we didn't do
to do that demo,
on that three-node
cluster, because it's only
a three-node cluster, we went
to about 2.3 or 2.2 gigabytes
per second read for
thousands and thousands
of processes running at
the same time on a cluster.
So this is going to give you
a nice view of the cluster.
But if you want a
little bit more,
deeper details on what's going
on, Grafana is a good example.
Stackdriver is also
a good way to take
a look at what's going on and
statistics on the cluster.
Grafana, typically, will give
you information on latency,
number of IOPS.
This is something
that you set up.
We're going to give
you some templates
to be able to see that.
But see, for example,
yesterday night
you were not sleeping and
playing with that stuff,
you launched massive
amounts of nodes.
And at a point we
had 3,000 clients
running on the same
time in the cluster.
And we actually reached
around 1.6 or 1.78 gigabytes
per second read
throughput on the cluster.
So this is going
to be very useful
for you to take a look
at what's going on,
if you want a little bit of
a deeper look on the clients
that are connected onto the
cluster, which one is using
what, which one is using
throughput or eating
all your bandwidth
and things like that.
You're going to be able to
do that through Stackdriver
and be able to track
the activity on all
the different clients that are
running onto the cluster, which
are, right now, I don't know
how many we have right now,
many connections, but
just yeah, we're climbing.
So it's launching a lot of
stuff on the cluster right now.
And again, we don't have time
to go into the crazy detail,
that this is going to give
you as well here the nodes,
actually, the [INAUDIBLE],,
the storage nodes that
are used for the rendering.
So the load balancer
on top of Elastifile
is going to fully
manage, fully balance
the load of all the
different compute process
on the three nodes.
So it's going to distribute
that on to reading
and writing onto multiple
disks into the cluster.
And you see here some
of the information
of how much a node is
going to give you in terms
of performance on the cluster.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: I'm just going to
show a couple of other things.
There's a couple of other
things that are already running,
or that are running right now.
So remember I mentioned
fluid simulations?
Well, I've got a
massive ultramem machine
with 160 vCPUs running
five concurrent fluid sims
that I'll show you in a second.
But this is all just
writing the data, again,
to the Elastifile cluster,
right, to the same namespace
as everything else.
And I'm able to, on my virtual
workstation, directly read
that data.
This is the results of that
fluid simulation and reading
that data live off that ECFS.
And these are about
24, 25 million points.
So obviously you can't
scrub in real time,
just because it's got to load
all the data frame by frame,
but it's hitting it pretty
hard to be able to visualize
all this information.
And then in turn, I can use a
different application like Maya
to render all that data.
So this virtual workstation
has, obviously GPU attached.
It's got one of our new Nvidia,
the touring class GPUs, the T4,
and that enables me to render
in certain renders which
are GPU-capable.
So I can render this scene by
going into this V-Ray IPR here.
And it's going to render
locally on the GPU.
Again, all this data is
stored on the Elastifile, all
that mesh data that you
saw there earlier and all
the animation.
So this is rendering
on a single T4.
So it's really
hammering that GPU.
That's the local T4 GPU, but
I could have an entire cluster
of GPUs as well.
And V-Ray has the ability to
distribute its render workload
to multiple machines that
all have GPUs attached.
So if I turn on
distributed rendering,
I can connect to
all these machines
as part of my GCP project.
And each of those machines has
four GPUs attached as well.
So this is addressing
a total of 40 GPUs.
These are all
reading and writing
to the Elastifile
cluster, again,
because they all just
have the same outpoints.
It's just a Posix file system.
YANNICK GUILLERM: A shared
cluster used for many things.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: It's
a shared cluster,
it's just a Posix file system
that they mount as NFS.
And what this is doing is--
where's my RDP?
So you could see it's connecting
to all those remote machines
and, give it a
second, there we are.
So now we're
rendering on 40 GPUs,
and you can see it's a lot
faster when I tumble around.
And this is an
interactive scene.
I could tweak the
shading, add lights,
change the time, everything,
and it'll just resolve.
So this is sending a
lot of data and it's
hitting the Elastifile really,
really hard, trying to absorb
and slurping all
this data into memory
so that it can compute
it across all these GPUs
and on the display here.
So let's go back
to the presentation
here, because I think we're
in the homestretch here.
YANNICK GUILLERM: Yes.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Let's look
at what you just saw,
the architecture of this
demo that you just saw.
We have all these
render workers,
we have all these sim
workers, and they're all
hitting the Elastifile,
but we're literally
writing gigabytes of
cache files to these--
you saw that 160 vCPU
ultramem machine.
Each frame is writing about,
I think, 20 or 30 gigs
per simulation.
That's times five.
So that's being
written concurrently.
We've probably climbed to
3,000 connections now--
actually, got more connections
because of all the GPU
render workers.
And then we're visualizing this.
We've got a virtual
workstation, and you
could have an entire
facility full of people,
full of artists on
virtual workstations
all hitting the same
storage appliance, which
is pretty impressive.
And so let's talk about--
YANNICK GUILLERM: Yeah, sure.
So what's next,
because for you guys
to be able to take a
look at that and test it
and there's different ways
you could use to play with.
We've built a solution Google to
be able to, like I said before,
to announce our
cluster with Terraform.
So in just changing few
variables into a Terraform
script, you can launch your
cluster, a minimum cluster,
add some nodes, so add
capacity and performance,
and then shrink the
cluster whenever
you don't need all those
nodes anymore because you
had to peak into rendering.
You can shrink its back to
its minimum configuration
and delete the cluster whenever
you don't need it anymore.
You'll be able to launch it
from Marketplace as well, like I
said before,
nonmanaged, unmanaged,
so it's going to
be really up to you
to add instances or shrink
the cluster yourself.
If you want a full managed
experience with the GCP
console, we have that
as well, and something
that went GA this week.
So we're pretty happy about it.
You can have, really, the
Elastifile in the console
itself.
No matter if you click, you're
going to be able to launch it.
And I encourage you as well to
take a look at the Quicklab.
Maybe you're familiar with
that company called Quicklab
for building some labs.
We built two labs, one on
launching a smaller Elastifile
cluster, get familiar with it.
This is really a
cool one as well.
We built one with Blender to
do a rendering in Quicklab.
So what's really
cool with Quicklab
is that it's going to build
the entire Google console
environment for
you, the project,
it's going to give you the
user and all that good stuff.
So play with it.
And I think we're--
ADRIAN GRAHAM: Yeah.
So if you want to learn
more about OpenCue,
you want to hightail it to the
Moscone Center, breakout room
four.
YANNICK GUILLERM:
Gotta run there.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: My colleague
Brendan Doyle and Greg
Denton will be doing a
deeper dive into OpenCue.
And finally, there
is a new entry
to our cloud
Marketplace by Nvidia.
Nvidia now has a deployable
virtual workstation
that's somewhat managed in that
it takes care of all the driver
installation and updates
and everything for you.
So that is leveraging the
T4, which is our latest GPU.
We also offer P4s and P100s.
[MUSIC PLAYING]